i have 100 random minecraft players and
they're gonna decide who walks away with
thirty thousand dollars chris pick a
random player uh chicken man mr covalen
yeah i want you to eliminate 30 of them
i'm gonna feel so bad if you right click
on people you can see what they plan on
using the 30 grand for this person wants
a lifetime supply of pizza you get the
point covalent you got to pick 30 of
these people and kick them from the
challenge i want this guy gone well the
guy is gone get him out he's getting so
power hungry he's not a rampage get out
dude oh no covalent waste you have three
people left to eliminate choose wisely
wife and i are expecting this guy's
about to have a child oh get him out oh
my gosh bye this guy's spongebob bagels
he gets to stay that guy gets to stay
but the guy having a child doesn't
fordrewski wants to help his family that
recently passed away okay uh are you
kidding
uh
keep him in dude
i was gonna say i'm not that terrible
get him out look at this guy i think
it's a clear picture boom you have
officially eliminated 30 people the
remaining 70 players have been split
between these three platforms and this
time i'm letting chris decide which of
these three teams is getting eliminated
oh no banana fish hello do you like the
anime banana fish i've never watched it
oh that's all i needed to know he's gone
cesternino why does red team deserve not
to be eliminated we got the congo i i
don't see it danias dream is the color
green and dream is cool blue team has
fake anime fans red team sucks at conga
lines and they're the same colors dream
chris who you eliminating i'm gonna pick
red just solely because i hate the
recolor red bye oh no just rip 30 000
from all their hands and now that we
have 40 contestants server put them in
their dunk tanks
i need half of these people gone in this
challenge oh one jumped in already
he just walked into lava i need both of
you to pick a random contestant i pick
mr last airbender himself i need you to
murder five people in the next 30
seconds go okay do i just put the levers
just click the levers uh
oh 20 seconds you need to eliminate four
more just hit the levers he's not even
thinking about it oh the humanity oh my
god boom nolan pick someone let's go for
stitch disney dude stitch i need you to
rip thirty thousand dollars out of five
random people's hands okay why are you
okay with this he's going with the flow
here man before you eliminate them
brosceps this stitch dude right here was
about to eliminate you and screw you out
of 30 thousand dollars you have 10
seconds to plead your case and why he
shouldn't well i mean i want to become a
better streamer how much followers do
you got i only got 28 man and how many
do you want i want your 10 seconds is up
stitch are you eliminating them
yes oh my god
goodbye bro
his streaming career stitch dunked four
more people and we dunked a few more
after that until there was only two
people left in this round to eliminate
this is the most important decision of
your life spyralio would you rather the
person to your right and to your left
get eliminated or you get eliminated you
know what i'm gonna be the bigger man
i'd rather be eliminated wow he saw
through it it was a trick question
goodbye
goodbye congratulations you are moving
on i feel terrible lost the challenge we
have to talk about dragon city the
free-to-play game that's available on
android ios windows and amazon exactly
dragon city has given away five free
iphone 12. why in dragon city you can
train your dragons to be more powerful
in battle there are many types of pvp
modes for you to play against your
friends or enemies as a fan of dragons
how am i supposed to choose just one you
can choose from over 1 000 different
dragons to build your own dragon city
you can also feed your dragons to evolve
it and breed two of them together to
make new ones breeding how does that
work just ask your mom let's go
there are several events to discover and
even better we have our own beast gamer
dragon then you can claim it now
participate in a clash of house maze
island event collect mace coin gold and
food and level up with your dragon just
get the beast gamer dragon to the end of
this maze and boom it's yours and
there's daily special offers and you can
breed it on september 9th and through
all of september if you complete five
dragon breedings you can be one of five
lucky people to win an iphone 12. click
the link in the description download
dragon city back to the video we started
with 100 people and now you 20 are all
that remain only one of the 20 is
walking away with 30 grand we'll still
love you regardless these guys are so
wholesome now the remaining players have
to talk it out amongst each other and
decide who goes and who stays and we
need to eliminate 10 of you oh no
there's two minecraft steves we could
get rid of one of them for simplicity
i'll start it out eeny meeny miny
moes
chris what do you have against steve
skins i don't know my dad's name is
steve all right sorry about that one
these two guys both have cat masks there
can be only one cat mask
stand on the side of the person you want
out i'm sorry mafia guy i'm sorry oh r1
in before we make the votes final please
your case i want to see i want to be
able to pay for college because my
parents already work so much for me does
that sway any of you people you have
parents lucky oh my god dysfunctional
tell us what you would use the 30 grand
for i want to take just me and my
grandma somewhere and treat her because
she does so much for me take your
grandma on a trip or pay for college
everyone's voting for rent sorry ren
oh my god hey one of my friends is here
pick two super dude 79 9 is my least
favorite number you're done
close your eyes and point out one two
three whoever's this influx all right
goodbye influx oh that's terrible okay
thank you okay bye and now we have 10
players remaining these contestants are
gonna choose a random spot on this stage
and i texted carl three numbers and if
you're standing on the numbers i texted
carl you're out carl did i text you the
number one no that texture number two
no that texture the number three
yes oh
whoa
that takes you number five oh i'm
freaking out ron what's going through
your head right now i am crazy nervous
right now
well good thing because i didn't text
him the number five that means with the
five of you remaining two of you are
going to get eliminated no no no no
please oh my god the texture is number
six
oh my god oh no i'm sorry
carl did i text you the number seven no
oh
carl did i text you the number eight no
at least only you two remaining oh
please not stitch carl dad text you the
number nine
yes i'm sorry
and disney dude that means you survived
by the skit of your teeth oh and now we
have the remaining seven contestants
hovering over a pool of lava a 60-second
timer just started every minute one of
you is randomly getting kicked
but here's the thing if one of you jumps
off and jumps into lava you're
eliminated but you can guarantee someone
here immunity i will give whoever teams
up with me twenty five hundred dollars
oh
of that thirty grand what a cheapskate
three
two one all right the first person to
get kicked is dysfunctional oh
no the 60 second timer just started
again who wants to give me immunity and
i'll give you half can i do it to you oh
they don't trust each other guys hurry
yes you're gonna lose 30k avatar are you
trying to do 5050 refund yeah ron do you
accept this deal egg is it okay if you
jump oh i don't really want to ron you
can get eliminated here ron i would jump
if are you five
four
three
all right avatar jumped off okay now
five people remain the timer just
restarted we still need two more people
to go disney i'll go 50 50 but i'm not
jumping yeah i'll jump if you hold on to
that bargain sure so disney you're gonna
jump off and spider you agreed to split
the money with him 50 50. 15k is better
than nothing
spider you now have immunity please get
off the bridge there's still four people
there's ron spider and you two and they
have immunity you guys can leave it up
to a 50 50 chance or you can work out
some deal you have 50 seconds left i
think i'm gonna leave it up to chance
unless you want to jump
i'm staying oh
we plugged both your names into a random
generator it gave us fox the
it's
fox
procs i'm sorry man see ya
you want the 30 grand because your
parents need a new house and this will
help yeah you want that 30 grand to help
out your mom and pay for your college
tuition
and you want the 30 grand to move out
and help your girlfriend that's sweet
yes you guys each have your very own
podiums and a lifelike statue behind you
these are the 97 people you eliminated
and they're gonna vote which one of you
gets the 30 000 in cash they vote by
standing on your color oh my god i hope
you didn't make a lot of enemies
they're now lining up for the other two
of you good luck we're gonna end voting
in 60 seconds
oh my god
oh my god
three two
one boom time is up screenshot it holy
cow look how close that is green has 33
blue has 29 and orange has 16. no four
people oh no it's my rallio i'm gonna
send you five grand spider i'm gonna
send you five grand did ron tell you yet
what happened no you just won fifteen
thousand dollars
you have five seconds to say what you
want you just won thirty thousand
dollars thank you guys for this this is
amazing thank you